what do I do if I don't want this piece
of food in my mouth oh show me how you
would do it what if I just did this
[Applause]
yeah I
cannot cannot
believe all the way from Shai please
welcome my absolute favorite Sarah Jane
ho yes Sarah Jane I've been waiting for
you to come back let's get right into it
first things first okay Sarah if you're
passing things like Rossy if you don't
mind passing that stuffing because
that's my favorite part of the meal and
if you have a side that is your favorite
part of the meal oh thank you I so
appreciate that what is the proper
amount true what is this okay I can tell
you that's not listen the only thing I
really want at Thanksgiving is the
stuffing so is this okay yeah is that
appropriate not too much hell no that's
not
appropriate so I would say that um if
you're the host the you should Serve
Yourself lost
oh that does make sense now that you say
it all right wa wait can I just ask what
what is she supposed to do she supposed
to serve herself but she wants that much
stuffing are there tips can she do that
should she go hide in a closet to eat it
what do we do there we go yeah so you
only take one appropriate serving size
and if you really like it then when you
finish that you can take your second one
oh all right what about if we have a
tableside disagreement because who here
has ever gotten in an argument at the
Thanksgiving dinner table
anybody all right like let's just say
that like Andrew and I are brother and
sister okay and you
know there there's a last dinner roll
okay all right okay oh there's only one
left oh this be a situation do you want
it I do really yeah just Mom likes me
better dad's Rolex what you know what I
got that Rox I earned it that's
literally the only I wanted he died
because you broke his heart now this is
ruined and mom hates you too just so you
know you know what hates
you and so does Uncle Greg this is just
like my 15th birthday you mean you know
what the one that you took all the money
from my bot mitvah so that you could
have a nice 15th birthday yeah that's
right that's the one okay so how do we
do yeah um if there a f at the table the
host or other most senior person let's
say Mom and Dad Grandma Grandpa okay
um I don't know Grandma I don't know but
it's a good question
as a senior member of the family you
should be like okay kids that's enough
and then change the topic okay oh has
anybody seen you know XYZ new Netflix
show okay I would rather just like get a
little kitty pull out fill it with gravy
and make him wrestle you know what I
mean that's what I'd like to do well
before we go to break to Mona I hear
that we have another
call yes I have Michelle from Charlotte
North Carolina Michelle what's your
question
lovely hi my question is I am planning
to take my boyfriend home with me for
Thanksgiving and I really want him to
impress my family can you give me some
tips well before you answer the question
um come join us at the table actually
Demona because um I want to know also
what happens with a couple who has too
much PDA at the table
[Music]
deona